je me laisse quand on a un talent comme
le vôtre
horani en enfer on ne sert pas au
paradis
jamal d'état je suis la mère mais je
reconnais ce résultat je remporte
apportez moi
à placer dans les tronches espadon on
ateliers je suis un projet qui réclame
beaucoup de temps et d'attention
la police faisant un cocktail ressortant
à quatuor d'illégal si je fais ce soir
je devrais leur effet sur la toile un
million
c'est un flic je veux juste que tu
effaces blanc
tout est réglé t'as jamais tué personne
pour renvoyer l'ascenseur m et le compte
des changements
on va commencer par des cartouches
2 il a alors je te fais moi tout petit
gonzesses tués sont mes couilles
un braquage qui a mal tourné je voudrais
tournage et sur un disque on essaie ses
cartouches on a déjà vu des pareils toi
c'est chiant
et il est peut-être mais il va falloir
fouiller du côté de chez nous
on a très peu de temps pour savoir qui
nous abuser
besson
mais bien
le conneries ça serait chouette ça peut
coûter très cher
si j'avais été plus loin de tout ça
serait pas remuer